Thank you for the invitation and I'm
glad to give up through then
presentation or Basil Confederation
meets a title as come to a vision meets
social media social network.
Actually a worry in this slice,
I were introduced to the works that we
have down in tens and Alf and as this
techniques is one or some research
topics in our labs and as a,
this topics can be shifted with the,
with the product of our company.
Okay.
First I will give our introduction of
brief introduction of our company.
So I'm never sure whether have you heard
tensen before?
Actually 10 center is,
um,
one of the largest internet company.
I think I can say that not only man of
China,
either on all over the world.
So this is the one of the largest,
if not the company and the market
capitalized is 500 billion US dollars.
So I think that even comparable with
facebook or even larger than facebook
and in sometimes,
and also we have several products and
several,
several trends for the most important.
One is a social,
social,
not social media,
social network.
So we have wechat and uh,
they say which are also,
we call the wishing in Chinese.
So we chat and Oscar Qq.
So this is a two types of instant
messenger or something like that.
Facebook and Instagram,
I mean us and also we have games and the
tencent games is the largest,
I think that's the number one game
company with have the ratio of you in
the USA with the over 10 billion US
dollars in 2016.
And we have several,
you know,
maybe someone is familiar with summer a
sale or should we have already acquired
80% of the officers shares.
So this is a,
we think that we are the largest.
We,
we are the owners are the eight
percentage share.
The owners are so sale.
And uh,
also we have some content working on
incontinence,
something like that.
Tencent video,
this is something like the Netflix and
also the tencent music.
There's something like spotify and we'll
have the largest a copywriter in a
amount of China for the mill.
That corns and also we have tens and
news.
So it about content.
And also because the Tanzania,
one of the largest internet companies.
So we have the other,
you know,
the businesses.
That's how as a finance or insurance or
something like that,
this is all based on internet.
Okay.
So these are the main structure of
tensen and in the next hour give birth
instruction.
But Tessa allies that I were,
I'm now in,
so it tends to an Arab have actually is
funded in 2016 and we have two
locations.
Why The or China in Shenzhen?
I'm China and a one office is Seattle.
USA.
Okay.
Actually we have four research topics
under the center is the machinery.
It is,
we've focused on the basic machine
learning,
uh,
the machinery series and also large,
large scale machine learning platform.
And as well as the,
and based on the machine learning part,
we have three application and research
areas come to vision,
language and speech.
And uh,
we would like do something actually
from,
for this that we focus on the areas of
this application and we'd do some or
reinforced learning for the decision and
also general agent for the creation.
And also we would like to maybe make
some combinations for the [inaudible] of
the world of the humans of the world.
Okay.
So,
uh,
in the following,
in a falling out this lecture I will
give an introduction about competitor
varies the works that we have done in
computer vision.
And uh,
we from the low level image and image
video processing to the middle of the
image we do analysis and the human that
depot was the major and the video
understanding.
Okay.
And we have done several works here,
subtract or start transfer the husband
and said Lucia.
Under the hazing I would like us to like
some topics that had already this
technology.
We have already got pop paper publish
and also shifted to the product.
And the second is the image analysis.
We focusing will,
I will try to introduce some process
automation and as a video interest
attractiveness and the video,
uh,
classifications.
And also in the last four,
the even harder deeper learning.
In a deeper understanding of the videos,
I will give some influx images.
I will give some instruction about
captioning and also the natural language
we do localization.
Okay.
First they see the video stock transfer.
Let's say they'll give a brief,
uh,
image about the video start transfer and
we'll have the videos and we have a
style imagery and we perform the stock
transfer.
We would like the style of videos to
preserve,
to preserve the content of the video
sequences.
And also it will borrow the style
information from the stout stout image.
And the most important is,
and this is very popular in 2016 as a
prisma,
but nowadays for the video,
we have the,
we are the first work working on the
videos for the video.
This is the most important thing to
maintain the temperature consistence
between adjacent offerings.
So from the,
you know,
from the sucrose here,
the temporal we have compared with the
traditional image style transfer and
though,
oh,
compared with our proposal mastered,
the image is traditional image start
transfer cannot maintain the
consistencies.
So the circles and the box stays there.
You can see that as a style changing the
changes a significantly.
But for our video part,
it can maintain a good consistency.
So this will prevent,
it will,
uh,
it will eliminate the chattering jet,
the flickering artifacts in the videos.
Okay.
So this is the Memphis and was a man
network of our video stuff transfer.
And the first party is a style stylized
and network.
This is a very traditional and a,
we have a a encoder decoder encoder,
decoder style style and we'll have the
encoders.
We escaped,
we connected with five restaurants,
rest blocks and as the decoders.
And after that we realize the last
networks to computers are stylized
network and a content loss network and
also the uh,
the temperature loss.
So with this loss there's no well
designer we can,
we can try the networks to makes an
network had,
can burn,
can preserve the content and the ad well
as introduced the style and as most
important and can preserve the
consistency between our jason the
frames.
Okay.
So for this or special training,
we have the two frame coordinator
training.
So it means that we input the address
into firms,
into the network and the then utilize
that design as obsessive as it design
the loss function to train the network.
And also,
uh,
another,
another advantage is that we do not need
to computer optical flow information on
that,
on the fly.
So it means that we can't,
well we can't,
well Mexico we can well Max though
inference very fast because of which do
not need to make a computer that optic
flow.
Normally the optical or is our most
complicated part in video parts.
Okay.
And I see that it,
because we are uh,
you know,
[inaudible] instant message APP is so
the person who will share their food,
their pictures in with the,
with the,
with their friends.
So the picture that may be taking and
the different conditions for this case
we want to handle the,
yeah,
makes the image quality house the house,
but for the low light images.
So we have,
if you take an image in the low light,
it can now you cannot define it cannot
find the edge of the content and also
the color.
You cannot find the,
uh,
you cannot take the right colors.
So we proposed a method to enhance the
low light images and we have the image
here and with Medicaid displayed to the
original video you made part and also
the age apart.
So because the algae the most selling to
the human perception.
So for the low light in low light to
input our regional part we do could we
use a [inaudible] style to encode the
image and the color image,
a catalog or no results.
And also for the age part we utilize
also something like the encoder decoder
and the afterwards we have the skip the
layer and the ways the island style to
catch the edge information.
Then paste this to the continent
formation and eh as an also the edge
information.
We'll combine them together then to have
enhanced the quality of the images and
then we got some perceptual losses and
also other adverse or loss is to enhance
the quality of the image.
Okay.
This is some of the results and we have
the first row is a low light images
provided and we use the our network that
we encounter.
We can,
well rick,
we recover the content of the image and
also the colors that can be well
preserved.
Okay.
So this is,
this is a one pot of,
we can share the image,
improve the image quality and uh,
the next is the next work is a mobile
pose estimation actually for the post
has measured helping well to study the
[inaudible] had been well studied but
for the mobile part if we need to
perform the network compression and also
Makayta to detect the scattering of
other joints very accurately.
So this means this part when mostly
focusing on the network compression and
the networks are proning.
Okay.
So they,
we shifted the network from the pcs to
the [inaudible] wise and we can perform
the detection of the person that Marty
persons and also for some front end
background and something like,
and the also instances to the uh,
to the colors of their closest.
And as they see the demos here and then
the first,
the latte.
I think that this is a maybe for the
projection party.
So this is not for real time.
And they see the 22 key points for the
joints of the persons under the under
the left.
Why is the way considered to detect the
hand?
Because the most of the hand,
the hand is detection will we'll
facilitate our,
you know,
the purchase,
the interaction with the,
with the phones,
all the,
all the TVS.
Okay.
And also for our mobile post estimation,
we have some,
you can see that for this one we are
Robinson to the full or half body,
half body,
half body.
That inclusion is on the half bodies.
And also we are,
we are able to perform a single or
multiple persons.
And also we are,
you know,
we are insensitive to the dressing
colors or the other.
They are the dressings and also we are
robust.
The to the front and back,
even from the front and back we had to
tack to the joints under the uh,
under the,
under the uh,
information of the scallops.
And uh,
also we have already deployed this
techniques into mobile Qq.
And for this one,
this is uh,
the,
the left,
the right one is that detector of
matter,
person of the scallions and the
laughter.
Why is that we have the skeletons and we
can have a dancing machine so we can
follow the,
you know,
the guidance that underperformed the
dances and the zen,
they say they're very interesting to
interact with the phones or interacted
with the TVS.
Yeah.
So you can,
with this one we can find that the,
you know,
with the disciplines detection we can
track that can match your positions with
a designed other specified the actions.
Okay.
So this is,
I work on the post that information.
Okay.
And another topic is very interesting
topic either for the video
attractiveness attractiveness.
Now that,
because for a,
we have the tencent video,
so we have a lot of,
a lot of video dramas have a lot of
times TV series uploaded on the website.
So we want to find whether the users is
interested in to some part of the
videos.
So we would like to,
whether we can predict the video
attractive from the only the visual
information or the outer inflammations.
So for this one we have the video input
and we,
sorry,
we have the video input and also I also
is associated with the auto import and
that we would like to predict it's
attracted us under the crunchiness is a
orange line ended up predict wise is a
predict ones.
Either you the Blue Line actually for
this attractive,
it is very hard to get the ground truth
data.
So we utilize the views because this is
a tencent video have a lot of
registrators.
So there are many,
many of you,
many,
many viewers at this time.
So for each of these is this,
each of these values in each points,
it means that at this specific time
harmon person have already have already
watched this video sequence at this
specific time.
So the,
uh,
the statistically the larger of the
number,
it means that their amendment,
there are a lot of men,
a larger number of person watching this
video at this moment.
So this prominent,
should it be the machine,
uh,
more attractive,
much more attractive,
attractive than they other with similar
values.
So we we utilize this video as a
checklist.
Crunch,
choose value.
Okay.
So,
uh,
for this task we built a large large
large scale data set.
We have a one style about west of the
pepsis and the in total about seven to
eight hours.
And uh,
there are,
we consist of 2,270
episodes of American dramas and also
search.
So the two Korean dramas and also seven
episodes of China's drummers.
So we have this one,
we can see that diverse of a types and
we have also the v the view information
as we can,
you know,
start a Mackie to the robusta,
to the video or check themselves
studying.
And the full,
this is a statistical information of our
data set and the,
this is a number of the episodes and
this is a number of the views,
attracting the views and the,
the law once in a lot.
Okay.
And also besides of the views actually
for it,
because it's the father tencent video,
you are for the v the video platform,
you will have some of the other better
data or some other user engagement tree
formation.
They are the nine catchment information
would crowd is a start of a,
is a stat of the forward and the end of
the forward,
the start of the backward and the start
of the uh,
end of the backward and also have some
pallet screens and doubling the number
of the billing squeeze and as the likes
of the polling screens.
And also we have the,
the,
the forward skips and a,
the first,
the word faster.
We were real wind skips.
So with this ones we can get another
more information about the user
engagements with a video with as this
user in catchments of videos,
you can can have more info,
more detailed information about,
they do our checklist and we can pass on
these engagements to analysis more.
Uh,
Alana's more about the human behaviors.
Okay.
Uh,
as we mentioned before,
we would like to make a prediction about
the attracted from the audio and the
video,
all the information and the visual
information.
So for this,
two different modalities because we have
a audio part and the other visual part,
so we four,
we proposed three different theorists.
Strategy.
Why is in the low level and a y in the
middle of error and the wine in the high
level.
And uh,
they see that three star.
This is the structure of the film part.
And uh,
we have also each part we propose,
we utilize,
we perform our contact skating here.
Okay.
So based on this,
this architecture that we perform,
that prediction and we,
we have the,
we also propose us three,
the three criteria to evaluate whether
we can actually the pro,
we can actually perform the Eh,
uh,
accurate prediction.
So we have,
we have the four metrics and a then
we'll compare to with different visual
representation from vg to inception to
rest,
not.
And therefore the other part would
compare with MFCC and an and also the
[inaudible] part.
So we can say that you consider all the
auto feature,
that innovative feature together we can
get better results and better results.
But if we can sample the middle level,
high level and a love of fueling
strategy together,
we can get to the best of performance.
So understanding that run and nothing
and nothing to note that is,
I will have the,
if we have the engagements,
the is that is the behavior of the
users.
So we can,
if we can get an engagement so we can
make a very accurate,
very accurate prediction on the video of
checkmates because if they like it,
it will watch it and otherwise they will
leave this,
leave this videos so that the human
engagements you the most important part
in the indicator,
the indicator of the video checklist.
Okay.
So these are for the video
attractiveness starting.
And also we started,
we make some study around the video
classification and as a mentioned there
before them and mentioned them by Lisa
before the moment at the moment,
same time,
the three seconds of the video that also
about Vedo complications,
right?
And then a nother before that,
there's a,
uh,
there's a benchmark tests that aren't
the ucf one zero one.
So we perform for this part,
we perform the two streams,
we utilize that to stream [inaudible] on
the,
on the video classification and the one
stream is,
uh,
describe the content.
And once from it is crap.
The optical information optical flow
meet means that an emotion information
between adjusting the frames and we
proposed a principal back propagation
propagation that we forward all the
snippers so the forwarding Romanian can
capture all the information of the
videos and but for the backward we will
perform a selectively to backward only a
selected number of snippers netplus.
So one info wine,
a wine,
one benefit is that from this efficient
backpropagation we can't get no,
we can perform a efficient and training.
And uh,
another benefit is that we can also
perform that it's named Paris in
different scales to characterize the
emotion that different emotion formation
in the videos.
Okay.
This is our,
uh,
results and for this,
that sets the pippin that here and how
even now to achieve the type one error
rate in about only 8.6
the percentage.
So this is a slow,
this is smaller than the other
competitive models.
Okay.
Also for the beetle classifications,
we we po,
Po,
we're participating in the youtube,
Youtube eight main and challenge the
here and now for the Youtube 8 million
challenges here.
They only provided the weight of the
features for the visual features and
it'll auto features.
So we work on the audio and the video
feature to perform the video
classification.
And a we for this is that we perform a
tooth two level consultation.
Why in the end the video liable.
So the Beta level where average is uh,
the all the frames together to get a
little bit of of the representation and
uh,
we propose the amount of fuel in layer
here as a deputy here and as empathy
with,
for the customer fires,
we tried to mix mixture of experts and
luck.
Global accuracy.
Precision is Arbutus only 0.82.
Okay.
And also we performed the friend level
classification.
Now from a level of transparency
[inaudible] it very intuitively to have
the LSTM and all that Gio to model the
sequential data.
So for the video,
the video feature,
this is the can be viewed as a
sequential data.
Say We,
so we utilize the about directional lstm
and [inaudible] and the GRU and also we
consider different,
uh,
different emotions information.
So we perform our motto scale wise.
So for each scale we perform,
we perform a bad direction,
but direction of Gru,
uh,
our lstm and the JP here,
the global,
the global average precision is
thereupon 0.83
and a if we consider the video level
part and as a frame labral part
together,
we can get as a,
jp is the 0.84.
And uh,
we achieved about to the force positions
number four,
the first productions over the 606 400
submissions.
Okay.
So this is about the video and image and
the data analysis.
Okay.
Afterwards I will ensure that I will,
uh,
afterwards I will give a instruction
about some workers who would have done
on the learn on the understanding.
One part is the image or understanding
here and the image I understanding this
is a very difficult part because we a an
image to understand the image caption
and the image is a very difficult part
because we're not only to understand the
image content,
but also we need to learn the language
of the properties or the behavior of the
language of compositions.
And also we need to perform a Amati
Motel interactions between the image and
the sentences.
Okay.
So for this one here,
we also utilize our traditional,
something like the traditional
architecture for the image.
We utilize that image you see in to
encode the information.
And the week Max we get the image
representation in the global wise and in
the local wise for the,
if we have a saying here,
if half a million,
if you are familiar with sailing for the
last,
uh,
at the uh,
fully connected layer,
this is a global representation and the
for the intermediate convolution layers,
this is a global,
they see the local representations.
So for each image,
a image,
a thing,
we can get the,
we can get to the image global and the
local representations.
And with this [inaudible] if we have
different uh,
uh,
the such as the inception and the rest
net or the egg,
we have different things that we will
have multiple,
multiple representation of the image for
each year.
For each set we have a global
representation and a local
representation.
And with this different representations
we can perform a marty stage attention.
And the Marty come,
um,
Maddie's stage attention can first to
summarize the information from
definitely encoders such as the rest,
not in separate ways.
You separately before and also the uh,
the vgg.
So we can,
we can sample this,
the present them together and also Max
this representative and to interact with
each other and for the attention part so
they can broadcast to their,
their information to the other encoder
to,
to let the other encoder know whether
you,
what information has been already
considered the for the generation part.
Okay.
If we had afterwards with a will perform
the multi stage attention,
then we'll utilize that.
Another decoder,
you did another uh,
another decoder to decode these
representations.
Two sentences.
The decoder.
Normally we can utilize our R and R and,
and uh,
the Alstom and Gio is the most effective
arlene's.
So,
uh,
we have in here we utilize that Lstm so
we have definitely,
we have the image,
you can call the catheter representation
and then we have the Dakota to Dakota
representation into a sentence.
Okay.
So this is first,
this,
this pay first.
This is,
this task is you need to consider the
information of the continent and then
you made in the image and also integrate
with the sentences to make the two folks
on the,
each object to is a generation of each
words such as for the persons.
You need to pay attention to the object
of the,
uh,
the person needs to pay attention to the
local region,
other the persons,
and then generate the words and the
father,
the hills.
You need to pay attention to the local
region of the image and then generates
the words here.
Okay.
So for these things,
we propel based on our multi stage
attention.
We have,
uh,
perform,
you know,
we have some Meta hour that's under Mac,
Microsoft,
the cocoa challenge here they say the
most,
I think that is the most,
uh,
most influence board influence that fat
on the image captioning.
For each image it will,
uh,
each image is a company with five
sentences under there about uh,
uh,
about 100,000
images and therefore h majors as it is
accompanied with five sentences.
So I think the appeared the pair Datas
for image.
Understand the pay data.
It is about 600 southern pairs.
Okay.
Based on this data,
you can perform the,
you can perform,
you can promote a training of the the of
your model and that's the image that the
results of the test data on the website
and a for this website we have,
we have several criteria to evaluate
your results and for the reason I say
that for this,
see the blue and the blue blue one blue
two plus three blue for and also we have
the meter Raj and cider say cid or this
is for the crd or this is the most
suspicious specifically designed for
evaluating the quality of the image
captioning.
Okay.
So far this fall for this we can say
that for the CFI and the c 40 we can
achieve all four.
All the metrics we achieve the top one,
top wide results and the compared to the
other.
Are there other models here?
Okay.
Also we also,
we have transformed,
we have,
we have a collector,
another Chinese dataset.
We have an image here and also we have
the image and that is a company that a
Chinese sentences and a we're trying to
models and also with deployed the,
we have released the results and uh,
we,
we build a late later program in we chat
so you can experience it if you have
the,
which had here.
Okay.
This is the Chinese for intelligent
image recognition.
Okay.
So for this image it had for the Chinese
give a brief brief instruction.
Uh,
very good disclosure about the content
of the image.
Okay.
And the,
for this,
if we have the image of captioning the
results,
we'll give a image and I gave her a
sentence or two describe the content of
danger.
We can perform first.
The most Australian boy,
eataly is a performer he made discursion
and other is that we have this sentences
that were going to perform the image
retrieval and the also as well as the
magic recommendations and also for the
visual dialogues.
And uh,
the most important.
I say if we have the image under the,
the discussions that we can help the
visually impairment.
Imparity he made a person to read or to
see the images.
Okay.
So this is the work I imagine captioning
and uh,
afterwards,
uh,
the last work that I'm going to
introduce is a natural language of video
localization.
They see the also are very challenging
challenge a task one to you utilize a
language we give.
Uh,
will you try,
are we giving our team the video and the
uh,
natural language or discretion?
The girl,
we would like to localize a stigma too
in the video which a correspondent to
the given natural languages Christian,
it means that if you will,
if we,
sorry if we have a very long,
they do say process and a,
we have a sentence that described such
as a woman rails,
keep a kite back,
lean forward herself.
We would like to localize this sentence
in the videos.
So this is a virtue as same as the image
captioning.
It is a very challenge because first we
need to understand the language and the
next that we need to understand the
video.
Same question,
but for the video sequence,
the understanding is the human
challenges that you majors.
Because the temperature,
we need to not only consider the image
con the,
the special content of the image,
but also we need to consider the
temporal relationship between the,
uh,
adjusting the frames.
So we perform,
we propose to us single story,
a single stream and natural language.
They don't look as a Australian network
for this part.
We have the we,
sorry.
Uh,
we have the videos and I will have a
sentence in the world perform frame by
word interactions or mentions here all
mentioned Syria matching pro matching
performance matching between the
sentence under the video.
Then we have,
uh,
with,
with this matching behaviors,
we perform a temporal proposals and have
different anchors.
Then we'll have definitely scores with
this,
the single stream processes we can
efficient and I localize the sentences.
He's a video sequences.
Okay.
And as this is some results of our,
this is someone who does of our proposed
a masters and they see the videos and as
they say,
have a sentence,
a man in a red shirt caps his hand.
And,
uh,
the,
the gray ones is our ground shoes and a,
the green greenland is,
we utilize a vgg 16 as the image as an
encoder.
And a for the blue ones is we utilize
the inception before as an encoder.
And,
uh,
the yellow was when you guys assist
really as the encoder.
So you can see that if we utilize a vgg
16 and,
uh,
inception before,
we can get a reasonable accurate or is
out at your,
for this,
specify the task.
We're up from all the competitor models
on this,
especially the task.
And therefore this,
that sat the,
for this,
the,
the camera was zoom out to show where
what four is coming front so they can,
you can see that,
uh,
the for the,
for the,
uh,
for the furion with during in the
inception before and optic flow,
we can get to the accurate prediction on
this,
on this example.
Okay.
Wait,
uh,
another,
besides we examine,
we examine the frame and the frame by
word attentions here and the,
for this sentence,
what for,
for this center and worked for in forest
for they say you can see that for this
all video sequences in the forest,
the first day is appeared over all
frames.
So the attach matters will be attended,
will be triggered at equally.
But for this,
for this workforce only appearing in the
forest first of frame so it won't have
this here.
Okay.
And uh,
uh,
the same observation that can be,
can be observed from this to give me
examples.
Okay.
So this is a lots of works that I
introduced about the computer vision
meets with no social network.
Actually,
besides that in our lab with not only
are we not only do the worker uncovered
variant,
but also we have some,
some of the other works on the AI
projects.
The most important APP or one of the
most important,
I projected the APP plus house and we
would like to deploys a or utilize the
AI technology to Max a health care.
And also the first,
the healthcare,
the first day is that we would like to
ut that ai technology or deep learning
and our to analysis a medical images and
um,
to,
to help the,
to help the doctors to Mac the uh,
to,
uh,
to have the detection to make the
diagnosis.
And the,
for this,
for this specific,
for this specific cancers such as a lung
cancer screens about for this
recognition rate is about,
is over 98 percentage.
And also in the future we would like to,
uh,
would you lie to the,
to perform a computer added that
diagnosis.
And we have some artists scripts about
the distribution of the passions and
also we have some medical images about
the passions and they would like to have
a doctor to attack max attack gnosis and
also even in the future we have to have
the doctor to Oh,
this design the treatment about some of
the disease.
Okay.
Another important topic is the Ai Gang
because the gang,
because tencent,
the game is the largest in the number
one game.
Company is a of the word.
So would like to utilize the AI
technology to evolve to be more deeply
involved in the game.
Maybe that designed the plane or
something like that to make the game to
be more interesting and a more,
uh,
more interesting to the you,
to the players.
Okay.
So I will give a brief summary here.
And the first I will give an
introduction about our talk computer
vision meets social networks.
And we introduced some works that we
have down in Tenson al up from that
research,
the product and something related to the
image of video processing,
understanding,
analysis,
something like that.
And also we have,
I have introduced the,
about some one hour,
uh,
several,
our important projects.
A applies to ax,
the ax,
maybe house.
Are you in the future?
Some robotics or something like that.
Okay.
So this is my lecture.
Thank you.